versions of it including the cooling one and it was just nice to kind of see your product as it
was empty we knew how close you were to the end um so we're we really like that okay and then
one last i'm sorry um you said dha about how much dha would you say it's somewhere lower in the
middle range middle range okay perfect uh thanks sherry this is a great pitch i i just have to say
I love the tie-in between the name, Burst, the description of beads that pop, as well as the crushable scent.
I think you've just done a really cool job in kind of tying that whole theme, kind of throughout the whole product.
Thank you.
It was your pitch.
It was very well thought out.
I don't know if that was you or Tom.
To be fair, one of our girls, it started from Fruity Pebbles.
Really?
Yeah.
One of the girls said, we want something in it that looks like, that you can see the texture.
Something like Fruity Pebbles.
That's the reason for the cutout in the bottle where you see those texture beads.
Oh, very cool.
Love that idea.
You might not be able to see it on there, but if you see it, yeah, there you go.
Who do you feel is your target demographic and price point with this product?
18 to 35.
We're looking for people, young, style conscious, experienced tanner, trend aware, active on social media, Sephora shoppers, TikTokers.
Yeah, I can see those products,
especially among some of the influencers
or some of the big tanners with big followings.
Because of the pop and the burst and the fragrance,
I imagine it's just something that explodes on your skin
as well as in your mouth.
Exactly.
I don't know.
Product points.
We won't go there.
I'm sorry, but this sounded way better in my head
than it did coming out.
Great job, Sherry.
Nice work.
I'm excited for the rest of the question.
Oh, you want price point?
Oh, yeah, price point.
70 to 85, kind of just coming in maybe a little bit higher than the Perfect 10 lotions.
And then we still want to keep it price conscious for that demographic.
Awesome. I love that. Great job.
I must say, I absolutely love the packaging on this.
Thank you.
And the fact that you show that it has like the little beads in it,
so showing the customer what kind of burst they're going to get, I love.
But now I got a question.
Question. Since you're going towards that younger career, like that 18 and older, do you have any type of shimmer or what kind of look is it going to have?
Didn't want to add too much of that.
So just a little bit of mica, just enough of that like super cute sun-kissed glow or enough with like, oh, you're going to see the glitter.
Don't want to go too glittery because we want to make sure it's still wear and go.
Okay.
Not nightclubbing glimmer.
Wear and still go back to the office.
this okay now is and you just have delayed DHA no instant natural bronzers like to see an immediate
bronzer as well okay so um now on color level of that immediate bronzer is it just going to be a
little bit or are you like looking towards making this like a darker brown in color because I notice
on the image it looks like a almost like a light peachy brown yeah almost a tan very very light
I love that.
I mean, this is, I think this is great.
Good job, Gina.
All right, so I have a question.
I'm getting a lot of nostalgia vibes.
Like, I feel like you were pulling from something that you've loved before.
Correct.
So what, outside of the beads, what was your inspiration for this product?
We just kind of melted everything together of the things that we've missed.
It's so interesting actually just sitting in the prep room over there
looking at all the lotion on the shelves
and seeing all the things that have come through
and all the things that we've missed over the years.
I didn't see ganja on there,
but that's kind of where our inspiration came from
and that the airless pump with,
I know we've had a lot of them over the years,
but the ambrosia and seeing your product through the bottle
was always so captivating.
You always knew exactly what you were getting
and mixing it together as opposed to popping the beads.
So we just kind of went a little bit,
a little different direction for that.
So I'm sensing maybe you have a brand
you would like to see this in.
is it start with c it might um and going back to the like this is a very sensory lotion obviously
you're playing show and tell with the product yes so give us um a little bit more of a description
on the pineapple mango and your inspiration on that fragrance because we're doing show and tell
with the beads so i want to be like pulled into the sensory of this product so give me a little
bit more on this fragrance so pineapple mango again going back to the fruity pebbles now obviously
Obviously, we're not having the blues and that.
But if you look at the packaging and you're seeing that orange and yellow,
that's kind of where our pineapple and mango is coming from.
You're kind of seeing it and feeling it, and then we're going to smell it.
Okay.
And then one more question here.
Is this a product that we can build on?
Do you see this like having more in the collection?
Absolutely.
Full collection.
Great job, Sherry.
Sherry, Sherry, Sherry.
Hi.
I have to agree with all the fellow judges.
Do you all agree this is a fabulous product?
Yes.
So in your description of this product, you started, I felt that you were leaning more skin care than tanning almost, right?
Can you tell me a little bit about why you feel that that's your lead?
Not necessarily more skin care.
We just want to have them together.
The younger generation are becoming more conscious of their skin a lot earlier.
I know when I tanned as a youth, we certainly didn't think at all about our skin and what would happen when we were older.
And now I feel like skincare is so prominent in makeup at such a young age.
So every time we as manufacturers are developing new products, we usually call it NPD or new product development
because we're trying to find a void or a hole in the market and we're trying to fill that.
What hole in the market are we filling with this product?
it? Well, let's see here. I think we're meeting that evolving customer demand. It brings innovation
and an aesthetic appeal with skincare as well. Okay. Kind of meshing it all together. I like
that. I'm going to blow a few little holes in this for you. Okay. I want to sample this product.
How am I going to sample this product? You mean like in a sample, like a packet? Yes. How would
I sample this? I don't think there's any reason that can't go in a packet. Okay. I think there's
room for it. I believe we had a product called Jade and it had DHA bursting beads and I believe
it also came available on a sample. So in that packet, would you have one side maybe clear to
see these beads and the other side for your ingredients and everything? I don't think so.
I think we can go solid packet. We're always going to have the bottle on the shelf and that's what
what we're going to sell from okay good i like it and i'm going to tell you something i'm going to
buy it so when it comes out i'll be in line well i really want to pitch to you are we done with
questions well sherry i was going to say is there anyone is there anyone downstairs that might have
any questions for sherry anyone no all right sherry do you have any any quick follow-up yeah
Yeah, we have a celebrity to endorse our product.
We really think Hailey Bieber is our girl.
Oh, Hailey Bieber as a celeb endorsement.
I like it.
No makeup, natural, glowy skin.
She's our girl.
Thank you, Sherry.
Huge round of applause, please.
Now, Sherry, you mentioned ganja.
Anybody here remember that product from back in the day?
It was hemp seeds in a clear lotion.
ocean and when you put them through the dispenser they crushed and you got the pure hemp seed oil
i have a personal best in the salon of selling that product i think i sold about 50 bottles in
one day because i loved it so much it's in the museum perfect we can have a look at it all right
so our next pitch contestant i'm going to bring up brooke and i don't know how to say your last
name oh the scores oh my gosh and then they're going to do their scoring at the end the audience
is going to do their scoring at the end. Do you guys have a score?
No, no, you get a score.
Do you have a score for Sherry?
Okay, put it on your whiteboard.
Alright, for those of you who
can't see as well, I will read
off the scores for you, but our judges have done
their score tallies. Oh no,
we forgot to give the markers for their
whiteboards. Can you just mimic the
score? Alright, Brandon, it looks
like you've got a score in place.
I do. I have a score. Alright, Brandon's
got a score. I'm going 95.
95. 95. That's out of 100, folks. A 95 out of 100. We've got Mr. Generous. We thought
he was... Didn't you want to be Mr. Wonderful? Now you're Mr. Generous. That's excellent.
And Jess? A 94. Nick, have you got yours ready? I'm an 87. An 87. A little tougher over here.
he's a bit of a mark cuban this guy michaela are you ready to roll we've got an 88 and miss gina
with an 86. excellent so good all right good start great start
next up we have brooke i need that piece of paper thank you next up we have brooke and is it
pettinger pettinger okay excellent so our second presenter brooke pettinger is an employee of
miami glow in brantford ontario she brought her fans you've got 120 seconds to wow us brooke
please tell us about your product hi everyone i'm brooke an employee at miami glow tanning in
brantford i'm excited to introduce to you head to toe featuring miami glow a luxury all-in-one
tanning and skincare created to be my absolute dream product i truly believe it could become
the dream product for so many others as well in an industry full of one noted formulas head to
toe steps in as an ultimate multitasker where most products make you choose spray tan or uv
primer or extender face tape or body only skincare or bronzer this product says why not all of it
this is a sleek sensual glow system designed to elevate every phase of the tanning ritual from
from prep to finish, from salon to shelf.
It's a conversation starter, a loyalty builder,
and a luxury icon in the making.
Let's talk about the fragrance.
It's called Coconut Fresh.
It's a soft tropical sun drenched,
a scent that feels like warm skin,
a salty breeze, and a champagne
at the sunset of Miami Coast.
It's more than just a fragrance.
It's your passport to paradise.
The texture is just as indulgent,
a weightless satin that melts into the skin
with zero residue.
It hydrates, smooths, and leaves your skin
Kiss by Stardust. To build the full glow ritual, we image pairing it with a pre-tan exfoliating
scrub, either sugar-based or enzyme-powered, to gently prep the skin without stripping color.
This product is made for the modern glow getter, anyone aged 18 and up, all skin tones, all genders.
It's perfect for the self-care enthusiast, the skincare savvy client, the tattoo trendsetter,
and the beauty minimalist who still wants to maximize the results. Now let's break it down
to what powers the glow triple dip technology which makes the product a spray tan primer a uv
accelerator and a light therapy enhancer all in one plant-based bronzers that are streak-free
pore safe and face friendly tattoo technology to lock in color and vibrancy collagen and microbiome
balancers to plump firm and protect the skin barrier derma dark which helps enhance melanin
production even without sunlight white tea extract a powerful antioxidant and moisture magnet
magnet and the soothing and toning technology to so your glow looks sculpted and not just shiny
the price point is 280 dollars and here's why this is the bottle that replaces five separate
products a primer bronzer moisturizer light enhancer and aftercare it's not just a lotion
it's a clinical skincare that meets celestial beauty a real investment in results and not just
a luxury splurge now let's just talk about the name miami glow it's not based on the scent of
of the JLo perfume inspired that came from the name itself.
My boss named her salon Miami Glow
because of the iconic fragrance,
and this product was created to tribute that same energy.
Just like JLo herself, the formula is versatile,
safe for the face and body, bold,
works with UV, spray tan, red light, and blue light,
ageless, thanks to collagen, and stage ready
with smoothing and toning and tattoo technology.
The vibe word for this brand is celestial
because it isn't just a tanning it's orbiting a whole new kind of beauty the
biggest creative challenge is designing one product to replace many without ever
compromising on luxury performance or skin safety this bottle belongs in
luxury spas tanning salons glow bars and skincare lounges anywhere with that
aesthetic meets performance and anywhere glow is currency and finally
the launch head-to-toe featuring Miami glow should be introduced in spring
equinox March 21st the moment the perfect balance between light and dark
the symbolic return of glow and the time for spring just in time for spring break summer prep
and seasonal a season of radiance so from light to sun and glow to the moon this is your all-in-one
tanning and skincare ritual before before during and after your tan light up every inch of your
skin with confident skincare and stardust oh my gosh so good really took us on a journey there
thank you for that that's amazing um i've got like goosebumps i love the idea of the spring
Ring Equinox?
So cool.
I'm going to tighten the judges up a little bit this time.
I want you each to ask one burning question with a follow-up if you need to.
All right?
So, Brandon, you start first this time.
First of all, Miami guy.
Love the Miami glow.
Got to say it.
You know, you said J-Lo, and she's always down in Miami.
Why am I going to buy this?
You know, when I walk into this salon, $280, right?
I think we all can agree.
Very expensive.
What?
Oh, Canadian.
Like $100 bucks less.
Yeah, that's like $50 bucks.
We're good, though.
But what is it going to be sitting on?
Because this is going to be the most expensive product out.
Why am I going to be gravitated?
Because no one working at the salon is going to be able to say all the points that you did.
So how is this going to resonate when I walk into the salon that I need that product?
It's your typical all-in-one.
So a lot of the time when we are at the salon, we talk about facial bronzers or leg bronzers as well as, like, spray tan, everything that we have, like red light and blue light.
And this just is an intensifier for all of it.
Okay.
So you would put this at the top of all the products at the salon?
Absolutely.
There's nothing as good as this?
Yes.
Well done.
Awesome.
Good questions.
All right.
A couple questions for you.
Outside of the head-to-toe story and the multi-use of it,
what are the two hero ingredients that stand out
that you would pitch to your customers
to give it that kind of skin care quality as well?
I would say the collagen,
which helps with keeping no fine lines, wrinkles, all that.
And then the microbiome balancer,
which just helps with killing any type of bad bacteria on the skin.
Thank you.
Now, since this is a head-to-toe product,
I have a question about just the viscosity of the product.
Is it thicker?
Is it thinner?
Is it light?
Is it, what is the feel of it?
Because like me personally, my body, I want something thicker because for me, I feel like,
oh yeah, I want it super moisturizing.
But on my face, I don't want that.
No.
So for me, I like the thinner based lotions where I find that's where I get a lot more
of the moisture and I find I get more use out of the bottle as well.
and I find that you can just use that all over your body and quick follow-up
question is this going to be super soft on the skin and if so are we talking
velvety or just like gentle absolutely so it's more like a satin against the
skin that's where the collagen comes in collagen really makes your skin really
satiny and soft Brooke that was one of the coolest best pitches and I it's been
a while since I've been to Miami glow but you obviously know your stuff so
So hats off and round of applause, like modern glow getter, glorious currency, cash flow
to paradise, kiss to start up, like just, you named all the buzz and all the words that
just made me feel like, yeah, like I really wanted this and I needed this product.
So how did you, when designing this product, or you guys when designing this product, how
did you want people to feel?
I want them to feel like they have it all.
I want them to feel beautiful.
I want them to feel confident and I want them to absolutely love the product amazing I love that
answer and great price point I'm a fan big big big fan I was literally blown away the whole pitch I
was like that's literally insane I'd probably buy it just by you saying that um just by having
worked in a salon at one point um what would would you still be carrying like facial products and
in other products as well absolutely so how would you go about selling those included if this is an
all-in-one product just because of course for your salon you do want to maximize all those sales
yeah so if they didn't go with what i'm performing um i would show them just your regular tanning
lotion and then i would talk to them about a facial tanner the importance of it you shouldn't
put any typical body lotion on your face just because it can clog the pores and make you break
break out so that's when I would state that perfect you killed it girl thank you thank you
Brooke huge round of applause that was awesome we're just going to give the judges here a quick
second to get their scores calculated anyone else have any follow-up for questions before
Brooke runs away okay who's got a first score for me
Nicholas? Nicholas. After 47 years in the tanning industry. Okay, we've got a pair of 88s. And an 86 from Jess. A 91 from Mr. Generous. And a 94 from Michaela. Amazing. Thank you guys.
Okay, our third presenter.
Oh, I remember I used to be able to do this job without glasses on.
Our third presenter is Daniela.
Daniela, please join us.
Daniela is an employee at Malibu Beach Tanning in Niagara Falls, Ontario.
All right, Daniela, please give us your highlight reel.
What is your pitch on your product in two minutes or less?
Hello, good afternoon, everybody.
I'm Daniela from Malibu Beach Tanning in Niagara Falls.
Does your 9 to 5 have your skin looking pale and dull?
Well, this lotion is for you.
This 45 times DHA bronzer has skin-complementing color,
giving immediate bronzed results along with imperfection blurring,
giving you an instant hue to your skin,
and it continues to develop even after your long day is done,
giving you gratification of longevity of the color you achieve with each tanning session.
With its plush silicone complex,
this will have your skin feeling hydrated and supple also a great a great way to keep those
tattoos prominent with its coffee and coconut scent a key ingredient caffeine and coffee seed
along with charcoal beads work to awaken those senses and your skin to bring vitality to dull
lifeless skin not only can you this can be used on your body but also safe for your delicate facial
skin, so your face can also reap the skincare benefits and color too. The charcoal beads will
help clarify, detoxify, and revitalize the facial skin. This will be sold for $1.65 a bottle and can
be found in your local tanning salons. The encapsulated charcoal beads will not clog the
pores on the face, but they will help revitalize. Some helpful ingredients like water, silicone,
silicone, niacinamide, which is a personal favorite, DHA, walnut extract, vitamin E,
peptides, caramel, coffee, and coconut oil. Anyone that wants to treat themselves and their skin to
a beautiful skincare regimen that allows them to achieve the best color possible with each and
every tanning session. Canadian made, the market needs this product because it's not too dark,
not too light. It gives you the color you are looking for when you are working and you're
You're taking time to tan to treat yourself to give your skin the best care and love it needs.
Tanning is an investment, so why not invest in a lotion that checks off all the boxes?
Not to mention, you can not only use this on your body, but also mention, like, the face,
and you're reaping all the skin care benefits.
Thank you.
Amazing, Daniela.
Huge round of applause.
You guys, the competitors really came here to bring it today.
You guys have some really, really creative ideas.
I love it.
There's an actual sample.
Yeah, so Daniella brought a sample of what she wants her product to look and smell like,
and she is taunting the judges with that right now, which is an excellent idea.
Coffee beans and all.
I just want to eat it.
Yeah.
All right, Michaela, you ready with a question?
I am.
Well, first, I just have to say it was an amazing pitch,
and the fact that you brought a sample.
I literally wrote sample heart right at the top of my paper.
Nick can vouch for me.
I just had a question about the charcoal beads you said right so you did say it's safe for the
face would those charcoal beads like absorb or would they be more of like an exfoliant charcoal
bead if you will okay and would they leave like almost like an immediate color on the face as well
okay thanks can you use your mic please Daniela when you're answering I'm sorry yes so the charcoal
beads will be burst into the skin once they're circular motion into the skin yeah I love the
the positioning of this product I love the color the charcoal or the coffee kind of theme throughout
the whole thing the lid for those who didn't see it looks like a little coffee bean I think it's
super super super cute thank you just curious if you were to have a celebrity behind and endorse
this product who do you think that would be I was thinking more of the lines of Sofia Vergara
because she's Colombian and yes so she would totally sell this if someone asked her what
what she was using on her skin and so that they would probably buy it love that answer
so i absolutely love that you flat out you're like and it's canadian mint baby i love it the smell
wow but now i have a question since this is a facial product as well how high is that dha are
we are we extreme are we just faintly just giving a little it's mid-range because it's on the facial
yes so about 45 grams yeah love it great job as a coffee fanatic myself um but i gotta ask you
outside of the bottle and of course the sample check check check love love love thank you she
put a heart i put a check i was like yep all right um i love the fragrance too but obviously
the bottle the fragrance coffee but what's the story with coffee in this product like obviously
want it to hit. So talk a little bit about like, is there coffee? And if so, what is it doing for
my skin? What's the story with it? What's the sales pitch on that? So it's definitely awaking
your senses. This is just a personal touch, everything I would want in a lotion, just
putting it out there just to awaken your senses and just to awaken the skin. As soon as the lotion
goes on the skin it will just give you the next level of confidence um daniella can i help i i
noticed you you mentioned as well the caffeine aspect of it so the caffeine is firming and
toning yes yes great thank you good stuff i think we all love the coffee i love the fragrance for
those of you that haven't seen the sample it's up here fragrance is absolutely amazing when when i
I buy this, I'm going to want to buy it a second time, but why?
I mean, what am I going to, when I use this product, I leave the salon, besides color,
what's my emotional connection to this product to buy it a second time?
The investment to buy it a second time is because how it leaves your skin feeling and
the longevity of color.
So you're going to know the prominent color, the tattoo protection, the plethora of skin
skincare that is in it, you would want to be a repeat customer because it checks off all the
boxes. Okay. And you said fragrance was, of course, the coffee fragrance, and you said a little
coconut as well. Coconut. Have you thought of a third node, maybe a citrus? So when I'm done
tanning, I don't have that heavy fragrance because at the end, if you have a vanilla or a citrus,
that's the takeaway fragrance. So if you haven't, you may want to think about that third node.
okay good to know but you can also pair it with a tan extender afterwards um anything with collagen
in it collagen banking just to help move the collagen along with the whole skincare process
love it i want to drink it now thank you amazing thank you thank you daniella huge round of applause
okay we're in our final two pitches our fourth presenter oh sorry judges oh well yeah you've got
Oh, are you guys that quick this time?
We don't need the Jeopardy music?
Anyway, all right.
Gina's got it.
Two from Mikayla, 89 from Nick, 82 from Jess, and an 87 from Mr. Wonderful himself.
Awesome.
Okay, our fourth presenter is Nicole DeMello.
Nicole is an employee at Beaches and Dreams.
Come on up, Nicole.
she also brought a fan club and she's got a little something something to pass out to the judges
here she comes samples paperwork if i see her slip the judges a 20 i'll let you guys know i've
got a better vantage point all right so nicole what is your core message we've had some wonderful
pitches today we want to hear you sizzle us short and sharp tell us all about your product
Let's be honest, who has time for a five-step body routine anymore?
Cleanser, shave gel, tan prep, aftercare, it's way too much.
Exactly.
That's why we created Radiant Glow Body Wash, your all-in-one luxury solution that does
it all in one simple step.
This is not your average body wash.
Radiant Glow is a cleanser, shave minimizer, pH balancer, and a sunless tan primer wrapped
into one silky formula.
And the scent.
It's clean.
It's breezy, beach vibe.
like fresh air, soft waves, and sunshine, all in a bottle.
The texture is unreal. It lathers up luxuriously, leaving your skin soft, smooth, and ready to glow.
And it's packed with skincare heroes like aloe vera, green tea, chamomile, and even caffeine to firm and energize.
We made this for everyone 16 and up because glowing skin shouldn't have an age limit.
This broader reach helps more people enjoy real results.
And since prepping your skin is a key for a long-lasting tan, Radiant Glow helps your sunless tan go on smoother and last longer.
At just $49, it replaces multiple products saving you time, space, and money.
You'll find it on boutique shelves, spas, counters, and luxe beauty aisles.
Our dream ambassador, Chrissy Teigen, obviously. Bold, radiant, and real, just like us.
Yes. Radiant Glow by Beaches and Dreams. Fun, smooth glow. Luxury in every drop.
Awesome. Good job, ladies.
Wow. Practice much? Best pitch. Best pitch. You guys did fantastic.
And I'm going to say gutsy move with a wash, right?
I mean, we all know how hard they are to sell, but you sold me on this one.
I think the fragrance, because we got another sample, you know, when you hit floral sometimes, it can be your mom or your grandma's fragrance, right?
Florals can be tough.
This is money.
This is very light.
It's airy.